l'administration maiden a annoncé hier
de nouvelles sanctions contre la russie
qu'elle qualifie de dévastatrice les
deux filles de vladimir poutine en sont
notamment la cible leurs avoirs aux
états unis sont désormais gelée elles
vont être coupés du système financier
américain le même traitement va être
réservé à la femme et à la fille du
ministre des affaires étrangères russe
sergueï lavrov et puis les etats-unis
ont renforcé les sanctions contre des
grandes banques russes et également des
entreprises publiques les états unis qui
interdisent tout nouvel investissement
américain en russie alors un officiel de
l'administration byden a confié qu'il
s'agissait de créer un cercle vicieux en
accumulant les sanctions contre la
russie mais à la maison blanche certains
admettent que ces sanctions sans
précédent contre moscou pour l'instant
n'ont pas eu d'effet dissuasif sur
vladimir poutine mais il assure que les
effets vont se faire sentir à long terme
et puis il y a aussi beaucoup à
washington qui aimeraient que l'union
européenne impose un embargo sur
l'énergie russe pour que les sanctions
mises en place par les états unis et
leurs alliés bien soit plus efficace il
y aussi beaucoup de frustration au
congrès chez certains élus qui
aimeraient que l'administration byden en
fasse plus par exemple en envoyant des
avions de chasse à l'ukraine mais on a
appris cette semaine que les états unis
forme et or d'ukraine des soldats
ukrainien au maniement des armes qui
leur fournissent